they wanted me replaced with some some
anyone from a minority background and I
was just like well obviously not because
I'm a journalist and how insulting to
the person from the minority background
to be told well you're a token the
arrogance and the way they just sort of
decide this person can't have a career
because of how they look and this person
can so I did say to this guy who was one
of the producers or whatever uh you know
I'm Jewish and he just started laughing
why do you think he was laughing because
he probably subscribes to the view that
Jews rule the media I'm done accepting
the this is a way that we talk about
different groups and we're not going to
put up with this
anymore Andrew G welcome to trigonometry
good to have you on the show we have so
much to talk about you used to work in
in the mainstream media now you do your
own thing like us on here on YouTube um
and there's a lot to talk about
including some recent events Nial aan
Yaki and a bunch of other stuff uh
that's happened to you as well before we
get into all that who are you um yep
Andrew gold I made documentaries in the
sort of Louis through mold trying to
Aspire to that kind of thing uh with
exorcists and UFOs and meeting weird and
strange people I got told after some
time that I had to be behind the camera
and no longer present my own ideas and
journalistic work happens to all of us
man just father time is undefeated man
it was it was horrific though and uh
yeah replaced they wanted me replaced
with some some anyone from a minority
background anyway so that made me start
a YouTube channel and get going from
there and and that's I suppose uh who I
am well that's really interesting not
least because the the very conversation
I playfully joked about now is obviously
a big part of everything that seems to
be happening in the media and frankly
elsewhere as well uh what was your
experience you you say that you were
basically you needed to be replaced with
somebody who's uh a minority you
yourself by the way are from a minority
background so that that's kind of
interesting we'll get into that as well
uh to talk to us about what happened
yeah um so I
was right we made this Exorcist film um
after trying to push it to the BBC for
ages I don't have a divine right to be
able to sell documentaries to the BBC or
anything like that uh but I made it with
a friend basically typically it costs
£100,000 or something to make a
documentary like that but we made it
with nothing like not even1 or anything
we just went and did it we learned as we
were doing it because we were so
obsessed with the idea of of making this
film we made it it won Film Festival
Awards and it took two years to pushing
the BBC pushing pushing pushing getting
told a lot I looked a bit too much like
Lou THU but for don't even want to watch
it but okay and eventually someone said
look if I watch it will you stop you
know just leave me alone and I was like
yeah please please just watch it please
just watch the film they watched it BBC
then they took it didn't pay me they P
well they paid us
£6,000 uh when you compare that to sort
of the Gary ler money you know millions
that they're getting we made this whole
film and they were just like take it or
leave it and they wanted changes and
things uh like legal checks and things
that were going to cost a lot more than
£6,000 so we ended up in debt uh to get
this fil film away and we made them
aware of that and they just didn't care
that was really frustrating because the
BBC um has this image or it Prides
itself on helping new Young talent to
get to a good start and they pretty much
did everything they could to not help me
and David my director to do that um film
went out did really well well received
celebrities were watching it and saying
it was a a great Mo you know I I would
say I was really happy it actually made
me depressed but that's a whole other
thing when you finally get what you want
you're like oh you know you want show
your teachers uh and the teachers are
all dead by now and that's it so at
least something to celebrate
yeah yes um anyway but the film's out
I'm excited at this point it gets into
2018s best of the BBC list it was a
whole big thing I was so excited and
happy in that respect and then it's like
okay let's go and talk to uh the prod
producers what's next I had loads of
ideas I speak five languages I wanted to
I thought if I'm going to try and do
something similar to what Lou THU had
done uh and for those outside the UK
he's you know journalist who who looks
at weird and strange subcultures I want
to be able to do it in different
languages I want to be able to
investigate in Spanish or German and go
meet these weird strange people that
other presenters don't have access to
because it's such a competitive genre
and you need to have something more than
everyone else if you want to have a
chance so I spent years learning
learning languages living in different
places um to to do this and I had
stories from around the world like mad
stories you wouldn't believe just mad
things that are going on that are just
Bonkers and I took them to the BBC they
loved them and we're sitting there
they're going oh wow wow this is a
people are being made to stand in ant
hills because they've committed adultery
in Bolivia it's like yeah that's crazy
and they were just very lukewarm they
wouldn't necessarily say what the
problem was but they were like okay
let's talk about it why don't you speak
to these production companies because
they act as intermediaries you get the
production company in the Middle TV
channel and me when I spoke to
production companies I had an agent by
this point my agent set me up with about
50 to 100 production companies over a
period of 5 years every single one of
them them I'm not talking about 99% I'm
saying 100% of them at some point in the
meeting while everything's going very
well jovial you're going to oh this is
great love these ideas said
unfortunately to get this to the BBC or
Channel 4 which in many respects is is
even more vehement with they're not
wanting white people you would have to
be from a minority background so are you
going to be okay with being behind the
camera and we would have a journalist
from a minority background in front and
I was just like well obviously not
because I'm a journalist and I
investigated things for years I learned
the languages I built the relationships
with Bolivian indigenous people who are
putting people in an Hills I went and
spoke to them to get this story I'm not
going to like just let some and how
insulting to the person from the
minority background to be told well
you're a token come and look at this
Bolivian whatever so that's what
happened it was very painful and sad and
upsetting because I was on minimum wage
at the time I was scrapping as most sort
of media people are until they take off
or whatever it is you're really
scrapping to you know what how am I
going to get money for the next food on
the table I'm living in all these
different places trying to get stories
together uh and it was a difficult time
yes I could have just got a job anywhere
you know in a in a shop I was working
but the the only way to make this sort
of dream of making TV work was to do
things like um copywriting online and
things like that which it doesn't pay
very well so every time I got a
knockback every time I thought okay this
is the time this person doesn't seem to
care that I'm white wow amazing uh
eventually it came up down the line you
know if they didn't say it the next
person they spoke to was like yeah it
can't be him unfortunately so that's
that's what
happened that is is so depressing that
is so so so depressing because what it's
actually saying is the caliber of your
work doesn't matter your talent doesn't
matter what matters the most about you
is your skin color well and also that's
why it's typically not creative people
who make these kinds of decisions it's
the people who are The Gatekeepers of
creativity which is so sad so I'm
sitting in meetings with people who have
zero creativity who have never in their
lives tried to go out on a limb and make
something and do something who have come
out of University somehow been given
these jobs as as I say Gatekeepers with
the arrogance and the way they just sort
of decide this person can't have a
career because of how they look and this
person can and they seem to not realize
that it actually involves Talent um you
know it's not easy to do I mean Louis th
is very good he's a good example he's
very good people watch him because he's
very good there's a reason people aren't
watching the BBC very much anymore
because a lot of the people on there
aren't very good because the creative
people the sorry the people in charge of
who can be on have lost sight of what is
the most important thing in
TV shows which is actual talent and we
see it it's not just in documentary film
Mak it's in comedy it's in dramas it's
in film it just seems that whatever you
want to call this thing diversity Equity
inclusion it just seems to have run
rampant and completely destroyed or
helped to destroy entire Industries and
corporations like the BBC well it looks
like they are on their way out and we
might talk about this more later I don't
know but I was watching have I got new
news for you the other day and um Ian
Hislop again it's a topical news show in
the UK that's very popular um and he
said talks about P Morgan and talk TV
and said something like well if anyone's
even watching that show with his pen
everywhere and all that and I thought
are you not aware that Pierce Morgan
gets millions and millions of views and
you guys are in a bubble that gets very
few views and to not be aware of that
when your entire job your entire um
status as as this sort of media Mogul
that Ian Hislop is is based on knowing
what is going on in the media for him to
not know that Pi Morgan is hugely
popular around the world whether you
like him or not is a travesty so they
they just don't know what's going on
outside of their bubble that is so
fascinating to me because as you know
private ey in hislop's magazine that he
edits uh they did a a kind of hit piece
or whatever whatever piece on us and
then I was like I looked up their
circulation and I was like well of
course you didn't hit piece on us cuz
we're so much bigger than you now and it
was weird to me because as you say they
simult ously their numbers are going
through the floor BBC they're canceling
shows left right and Center I mean with
comedy mock the week is gone Mass report
is gone live der poar numbers I'm being
told are declining and eventually will
be canceled as well news night has had
to rejig a bunch I mean we could go on
and on and on right so they're really
struggling but at the same time there's
this incredible like sneering
smugness of like we are the we are the
the people with the power and I'm just
like you're not mhm you're really really
not well all they have now is that
position as the Legacy Media I remember
seeing years ago um I was at a talk a
YouTuber was given giving where he said
exactly this to a at a panel he was at a
panel with like nap goo and BBC and all
these people and he was like the the
outside of the YouTuber and he was
saying oh there's something about it
that I still want to make my shows on
the BBC I still want to have Channel 4
and all these things and I think it's
that my parents will be impressed and
it's just it's so mad because the
numbers are huge on YouTube they're so
much bigger and you can attract a much
wider audience there is still something
and it's all they have left is this idea
that we are Legacy and we have
Gatekeepers the irony is it's less
Democratic but they position it as
somehow um more valuable well the idea
is that it's curated yes and therefore
better and I don't know that in 2023
that really is true because it's curated
by Gatekeepers in the Legacy Media but
it's not like YouTube is uncurated it is
curated by the public yeah whether if
the public click on your content it goes
up and if they don't it goes down and so
the cream tends to rise to the top
although I mean some of the stuff
18-year-olds watch is a bit of an
exception but you know what I mean and
and I thought I thought it was
beautifully summed up in the last few
weeks as we're recording this by this
incident with the BBC Radio five life
presenter nihala anaki who basically
went out and said what I think is
probably the most racist thing I've ever
heard anyone publicly say
which we'll get into and more
interesting than than him because you
know I have my opinions about him was
the BBC's reaction this guy said that he
has mental health issues because he's
surrounded by white people and the
reaction from the BBC was to apologize
effectively to him and say no we're
we're working really hard to reduce the
number of white people in an
organization that is already massively
over represented in terms of minorities
yeah it just sums it up for me and and
this is a guy who makes a really really
good salary from it while probably not
bringing in as much value as he costs
quite yeah quite possibly I don't watch
or listen to him very much he might be
very good at what he does there were a
lot of I've been on his show we had a
debate about comedy in which he
explained that Joan C's opinion on comed
is relevant yeah well what has John C
done in comedy exactly who's what has
John ever done for us exactly yeah yeah
neow I it's it's a bizarre one isn't it
because we've got a guy here who is um
in terms of privilege if we're going to
use the their words in terms of
privilege and status and all these kinds
of things in the top
0.001% of just the UK If you if you
expand that to the world people are born
in bins in Bangladesh and all sorts of
places right there is there's no number
that I can go on long enough with the
0.00 that is sufficient to explain just
how privileged and and Status worthy
this man is and I think that speaks to
the issues that we have with um
socialism and woke culture because we've
here's an example of how you get what
you want and it's never enough so he's
gotten what he wants by a million miles
better than he could have ever dreamed
of and he has it and now it's like but I
now also want people who look like me
around me and I want to start changing
the numbers of different demographics
and it's never going to be enough
because we all have as a human thing an
obsessive compulsion I think to start
making things neater and tidier around
us not me mate
unfortunately yeah everyone aside from
you though we're trying to make but
there is that control that you yeah you
want to create order and control over
your immediate environment yeah I think
that's right and I don't know if he
actually knows the statistics maybe he
doesn't know there's something called
Diamond diversity which is like the
neutral uh I don't know what you'd call
it adjudicator of um of of TV across the
UK so it's not just the BBC we're
looking at Sky Channel 4 and all these
different um channels um and when I was
struggling I started looking this up
Diamond diversity and the BBC use it
they all use Diamond diversity no one
seems to know about it in the public the
telegraph once ran a tiny little article
about them and nobody else seems to know
about Diamond diversity what they do is
they find all the stats of minorities
they don't include Jews of course uh but
other minorities uh and and how well
they're doing in the media industry both
on screen and offscreen and what they've
been finding for years now even before
the whole sort of woke apocalypse
started to to come come to the four uh
is that minorities are significantly
over represented on TV now the problem
is for these people who work at Diamond
diversity is they need to keep their
jobs right because if everything is
diverse they've done their jobs and
there's nothing left so you can look at
the latest report there's a new report
every year or two it's Diamond diversity
6 and you can look that up online and
it's mad it is mad and it really is
about that um overused saying but but
it's true that those who can make you uh
believe absurdities can make you commit
atrocities and I think you look at it's
very allwell and it's the first page of
the diamond ders they sum it up and they
say you know there's oh we really need
to work on getting women more offscreen
roles there's not enough offscreen roles
for women at the top in the senior roles
so you go and have a look at the actual
details and it's true there are more
directors who are men there are more
writers who are men not that many more
but a little bit more producers they're
pretty much equal when you go higher and
higher they're dominated by women so um
commissioning editors so The Gatekeepers
the people who actually hire those male
directors and writers are overwhelmingly
women which is ironic you know that the
complaint is they're the ones deciding
that and then the the show Runners at
the very very top the top top people 90%
are women but that's how they mess with
things that's how they try and get you
to agree to their ideology the first
page oh there's not enough women in the
senior roles because there's not enough
directors and writers who are women the
women are the ones hiring those male
directors because they are above them
now with diversity same thing happens oh
we need to get more diversity We need oh
we're still working really hard you can
see that people from Bame which is the
British way of saying minorities black
Asian minority ethnic are about doubly
overrepresented compared to the
population at large that's that's huge
that's more than a significant
difference it's particularly true in
children's TV I don't know why
necessarily uh comedy and it's
particularly untrue the only place where
there's slightly less than the uh actual
population at large is factual and
that's also quite funny really because
you know it's a place where facts are
allowed and you know that's where it's
not that way but comedy children stup
all these kinds of things significantly
over represented but these people need a
job so that's what's going on they're
pushing and pushing because they are
earning money out of telling us and
making us believe it and niow is
probably believing what he's hearing and
he's pushing this kind of agenda and I
don't think it's that farfetched to say
that kind of philosophy when taken to
its limit causes what happened the other
day at the top of the universities in
America does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate mit's code of conduct or
rules regarding bullying and harassment
yes or no they've targeted at
individuals not making public
statements yes or no calling for the
genocide of Jews does not constitute
bullying and harassment I have not heard
calling for the genocide for Jews on our
campus but you've heard chance for
inapa I've heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people so those would not be
according to the mit's code of conduct
or
rules that would be um investigated of
as harassment if pervasive and severe
Miss Migel at Penn does calling for the
genocide of Jews violate pens rules or
code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
Mill so is your testimony that you will
not answer yes if it uh is if the speech
becomes if the speech becomes conduct it
can be harassment yes conduct meaning
committing the act of
genocide the speech is not harassment
this is unacceptable Miss Migel I'm
going to give you one more opportunity
for the world to see your answer does
calling for the genoside of Jews violate
Penn's code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes and Dr Gay at Harvard does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as an individual targeted as at
an individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals do you
understand your testimony is
dehumanizing them do you understand that
dehumanization is part of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and and harassment yes or
no anti-semitic rhetoric when it is it
anti-semitic rhetoric anti-semitic
rhetoric when it crosses into conduct
that amounts to bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the board because we have this
Olympics now because everybody is being
pushed to start comparing who is where
in the hierarchy of ideology races and
uh all sorts of things um we've now got
presidents of American universities
basically calling for genocide of Jews
and I I that's why I think this is a
problem they weren't calling for they
were saying uh people calling for the
genocide of Jews uh is harassment or
isn't based on the context which by the
way we we talked about this the other
day on one of our raw shows it's like if
they'd been consistent about this
throughout the last however many years
you'd sort of go well look you know
universities in America bastions of free
speech you know the campus is where
young people go to be a bit crazy and we
must give them extra leeway this is
where they you know test out ideas and
then eventually they go into the real
world and whatever but that's not what's
been happening what's been happening is
for the last years or 10 years or
however long it's been it's like you ask
me where I'm from it's a micro that's
what's been happening so there's a
massive inconsistency there which which
you're pointing to and the thing with
with with Nal is look I I don't like him
I don't think he's particularly good at
his job but that's irrelevant my point
is something else which is how is it
acceptable for somebody to openly be
racist against white people or any
people and then for the major
institution that is funded by quite a
lot of white people by the way in this
country to then apologize to them and
that's why people are like asking me why
I'm going at him so hard uh I I'm done
I'm I'm done playing with these people
I'm done accepting that this is a way
that we talk about different groups
because these people think that they can
get away with it no you can't you're not
you don't have a monopoly on the
microphone anymore there are other
voices now and we're not going to put up
with this anymore we're just not I
think yeah I think you're absolutely
right and and it's something you guys
have spoken about before I mean the road
to uh hell is paper of Good Intentions
this idea and I think it needs to be
taught in schools a little bit this idea
that when bad people come they're going
to come and say bad bad bad and get
everyone is so childish it's so fasile
um and the reality every single time
throughout history has that has been
that people have come along with ideas
that at that time seemed Progressive and
right and right on and and useful and at
the moment I I think it's just that
humans I I am a bit nistic and I think
humans in general are tribalistic and
we're tribal and we you know we're
chimpanzees to an extent and we we do
feel anger and annoyance I was telling
you before we came on I get annoyed if
people on the plane touch me I'm annoyed
and there is a tiny bit of me going I
should kill that guy and I go no no
because I'm a I'm a real person and I'm
a human and he's just sort of
accidentally brushed my leg and he
deserves as much right we live in a
society as George castanza and Seinfield
would say so um I think we we we lose
track of that sometimes that we will
when allowed when it is permissible we
will be racist we actually will so all
this stuff about Prince Prince Harry and
unconscious bias blah blah blah there is
an element of that in all of us but it's
not coming from where he thinks it is
it's actually where's the place in
today's society where I can be racist
and can be horrible and N how's found
that place
unfortunately we'll be back with Andrew
in a minute but first we want to tell
you about this ingenious new device look
to break that bad habit you can forget
about having to go cold turkey there's
now a better way we're talking about
fume it's spelled Fu M and pronounced
fume which makes no sense anyway not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
does just that you can trade breathing
in nasty chemicals for breathing in
Fresh Air instead of vapor fume uses
flavored Air instead of electronics fume
is completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors it's a habit you're free to
enjoy and makes replace in your bad
habit easy your fume comes with an
adjustable airflow dial and is designed
with movable parts and magnets for
fidgeting which gives your fingers
something to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your habit I'll be honest I wasn't sure
what to expect with fume but they're
actually more flavorful than I thought
and it actually feels fresh the feel of
them is nice it's well weighted
perfectly balanced and they're made from
real wood which feels nice and looks
great too here fum has served over
150,000 customers and has thousands of
success stories there's no reason that
can't be you join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to try
f.com and use code trig to save 10% off
when you get the journey pack today
that's TR yfu m.com and use our code TR
to save an addition 10% of your order
today give it a go it might just help
you kick that bad habit back to the
interview it's really depressing because
I thought we'd got to a place or we're
getting to a place is a more accurate
way of summing it up where we all
accepted that gender race ethnicity it
doesn't matter when you're hiring
somebody you want the best person for a
job you're a football fan you don't care
if the striker is a Muslim from Egypt
like Muhammad Salah all you care about
is that he's incredible at his job and
for someone to then say they don't want
this particular racial group in the
office or to be surrounded by them is
abhorent was it Arsenal's women's team
recently that had to apologize because
they had no black players I mean that
that is taking this to the Limit I mean
a sport sport you just need the best of
the best of the best and that that was
just absolutely Bonkers yeah and I think
what it also shows as well is that the
institution is just completely corrupted
by this ideology and it gives me no joy
to say this because I love the BBC if I
think about my favorite documentaries
BBC if I think about my favorite comedy
programs very frequently BBC the news
everything about it the world service
and to see the disarray it's currently
falling into it's heartbreaking yeah
yeah it is sad I mean look these are
ideas that if you just think about the
ideas in the first place they're not
they're not necessarily bad taken on a
very minute level I mean you don't want
people growing up and not being able to
at all recogn you know there'd be no way
for black people to get into media if it
was a situ let's say the diamond
diversity came out and said actually
despite there being 18% of Bame people
in the UK uh only three or 4% are on TV
I don't know what the answer is because
I don't like the idea of forcing change
like that um Coleman Hughes is is a
great speaker and he was he had this
whole Clash recently with Ted Talks
because he thinks that they were
dismissing him and and and subduing his
uh video because um he was suggesting
that you know affirmative action in this
sense is not a good idea and he said
look if you want to do this invest in
communities from you know Grassroots
help communities from the beginning and
you should look at the communities that
are the poorest not necessarily by their
skin color because we know that in like
free School meals schools the some of
the poorest schools in the country that
um black Africans actually do
significantly better black people of
African Heritage significant ly better
than white kids um black people of
Caribbean Heritage don't do better they
do really badly as well as the white
kids you know so those are the so what's
going on there that's if if you do
really want to if you really cared if
they really cared about getting that
intersectionality idea right from the
start and going okay let's look at that
the poorest people are actually the ones
doing worse that's how it would be done
but I mean African kid kids of African
Heritage do really well kids of uh South
Asian Heritage like Nial uh do really
really well that's what I think if they
want to look at it that's where they
should be looking and and it's not just
affected mainstream broadcasting it's
also podcasting as well so tell us about
that because that blows my mind because
the whole point to me of podcasting is
that it's independent it's got a punk
element there's a punk aesthetic anybody
can set up a podcast yeah this is
punk wherever independent creatives will
start to make art there will be um
Psychopaths out there to control them
and decide which of them get through uh
I spoke to a punk rocker who's been
canceled recently Louise distress I mean
she's like a punk rocker and she you're
supposed to be able to say whatever you
that's a whole bloody point and the way
the agents have treated the way that
people have treated her and just not
given her her money I mean surely that's
a significantly worse crime than
worrying about uh her saying that uh
trans women are not women that's what
she
said sorry he has an allergic reaction
to that statement
exactly giving someone money I'm Jewish
what are you doing
I thought transwoman and women was what
was trans wom women no um anyway so she
said that and and people have just you
know taken advantage of her and and
kicked her out and not paid her and
they've basically said like oh well you
said these offensive things so we don't
have to give you money now it's Bonkers
right the podcasting industry is the
same thing also the kinds of people that
go into like wishy-washy careers like
ours they are wishy-washy to an extent
they're not like proper jobs in in some
respects it's uh media publishing I had
to get up at like 9 this morning what
are you talking about
I got here he was just lying around no
it's we're very hardworking but they're
not they're not the kinds of jobs that I
don't know I mean my parents didn't want
me to be a YouTuber I was just joking
these aren't real it's like when we
interviewed Bill Burr do not worry that
they're going to want to go into show
business and you having seen like the
way show business is and no show
business is awesome like none of us have
a real job what are we doing right now
say what is today today's Tuesday yeah
yeah oh we got jackets on and we're
talking microphones this is a
real
job I love that no no you're absolutely
right yeah so the you were saying these
kind of Industries they attract
Psychopaths who want to take advantage
and want to then put their print on
imprint on it but but like I said before
these are not creatives these are not
people who understand how creativity
works so just the other day this was a
week or two ago and it wasn't reported
in the media at all we had in the UK
there were two big sort of award
Ceremonies for podcasters again you and
I we're sort of lucky that we can be
outside of that really we live on
YouTube and we're not bothered by that
that stuff but a lot of people do rely
on that because that's how they get
their marketing audio podcasting unlike
YouTube has no discoverability it means
that unless you have a big name and a
good way somehow money to get your
podcast out there you can't really do it
whereas on YouTube if it does well
YouTube pushes your video out to people
so audio podcasters really rely on
marketing and award ceremonies are
pretty much the main way to do that at
the audio podcast Awards they had a guy
get up on stage uh Axel Kaku I think his
name is that someone can correct me
later um and he gave what was basically
a call to Arms against Israel just after
the October 7th um and really
passionately so he was supposed to just
get up and give an award but this is a
guy who is a farle totally untalented
person who in that podcast industry in
the UK is a big deal but outside of it
is no one knows who he is um he's on
stage and he was giving like a rallying
cry now you won't be surprised to know
that their main speaker there at the
award ceremony was one Nish Kumar who is
always at the center of all this as well
so he was also like getting them all
going yeah genocide they're committing
genocide there were a few Jewish people
in the audience relatively few despite
the the myth that Jews pervade all all
aspects of the media um but there were a
few there uh who I've heard from who
were just absolutely mortified gutted
and frightened for their lives but
that's how far these things go and they
got in touch afterwards with the audio
production awards ceremony and they were
just like well you know what can we do
it's what the speakers have said and and
so on but imagine if someone had gotten
up and said oh we we defend Israel's
right to defend itself or something like
that no would have been absolutely
killed so that's the audio production
Awards then you've got the British
podcast Awards who it is just
mindboggling what they get up to when I
first started I didn't have any
listeners or anything so I applied for
it but you read they do 33% of their
judging so they judge 33% on the quality
of the podcast 33 66% is like
wishy-washy stuff uh uh which basically
means diversity what what does that mean
just to interrupt judging on the quality
of the podcast are we talking about the
audio quality how it sounds or the
guests all the conversations how did
they I don't understand what that means
Andrew Well award ceremony is are
ridiculous anyway right well this is
what I was going to say is like I almost
don't I'm not even that interested in
this conversation this is no offense to
you because this is all the old school
Legacy bollocks yeah that we are all
refusing to engage in and that's why
we're all doing well right because it's
all fake the the only real test of
content is whether people consume it or
not that's it that's it the fact that
three people or 10 people or 50 people
in the room sat went oh this is good and
there's a brown you know like no one
gives a and they're all going to
fail and this is this is the thing is
like the BBC has started podcasts and
you're going why don't you look at what
actually works look steal our idea get
two people who are better looking and
funnier and whatever
impossible thank you
correct that's a good
joke and do the same thing but they
can't they can't because they can't have
the actual conversations that we are
having here because ideologically they
can't actually face reality and that is
all so let you know what my my I'm just
saying to you guys let these people do
their stupid Awards and do all stupid
crap cuz it just helps us yeah you're
right but not many people can get to the
levels you know that we have gotten to
so there are people who would like to do
things like us who are starting out and
we we got a bit of luck as well all of
us along the way no matter how good I
mean we try to be there's a element of
luck element of starting at the right
time if you start now maybe it's bit too
saturated maybe someone's working too
many jobs to take care of people they
can't do well in podcasting they're
trying and they just want to offer an
alternative view every single and and
and the marketing that that's why that's
why that's important for those people
for the podcast Awards it's one of the
very few ways to get your podcast in
front of people almost every single
nominated podcast is like Asian girls do
this the Masala podcast enjoy that oh
mate that's I'm hungry now a gay and a
non-gay they all called things like that
and it's just like even in the title and
it's is does anyone care about what's
good anymore and that's I mean that
speaks to your point doesn't my point is
I think look I there's no argument it's
much harder to start now than when we
did but the reality is
ultimately the beauty of the moment
we're in is there are no Gatekeepers M
so you can make it if you go for if you
have an original idea but let's be
honest if you start a podcast called
something along the lines of
trigonometry now and you did all the
same things that we did then it wouldn't
work because it has to be original to
that particular moment there were not
many people in this country doing what
we do now so the timing was important
you know luck Talent all of these things
come into play but ultimately if you
create something that AR answers the
need of the moment then you will make it
in the current climate and that's why I
just I really think it's important to to
to for people to hear that message it's
like all these podcasting Awards this is
all bollocks it's it's not it might help
you in the very short term but no one
wants to hear you know two Asian gays or
what whatever the it's called it's
it's really it's just a dead industry
and the more the more people understand
that I think the easier it's going to be
yeah I really think that by the way one
of the things you kind of didn't bring
up you mentioned being Jewish did when
you were being told you know we need a
different person in front of the camera
did you s did you raise the fact that
you know you were from a what is at
least in my opinion an ethnic minority I
mean some people would say Jews don't
count but yeah yeah yeah and I I mean
look I mean being Jewish I've been fine
I've had a fine upbringing but it's only
one generation back my dad had to change
our name from Goldstein to Gold because
of anti-Semitism because of what he had
to face and going into like a a rough
School I got to go to a posh school
because of the sacrifices my parents
made uh it's only two or three
generations ago the Holocaust I know
people are tired of hearing about it but
it it needs to be reinforced especially
with what happened recently uh at the
the colleges and I did end up mentioning
it but this was two or three years in
because I was so ashamed to have to sit
in front of a bunch of Gatekeepers and
say you know I've got this victimhood
thing it was always an anathema to me it
was I had to and I felt but I had no
money so you know terrible
[Laughter]
well this is the problem yeah no one
likes a Jew with no money you know it
goes against the stereotyp no one likes
a Jew full stop but a Jew with no money
yeah extra bad so I'm sitting there and
I remember having like for the 500th
time well the 50th time uh we can't
because you're white and I I didn't want
to say it and I was so ashamed and I was
sitting with my director David as well
who's not Jewish but we didn't we talk
about this stuff because I'm not a
victim I I hate that you don't want
people pitting you and I just was like
I've got to do something cuz David's
upset by this I'm upset with both
struggling trying to make it happen so I
did say to this guy who was one of the
producers or whatever uh you know I'm
Jewish and he just started laughing and
he said uh I I can't say what I really
think about that and I went okay and um
that was it it was it was it was painful
it was painful he started laughing
yeah yeah why do you think he was
laughing because he probably subscribes
to the view that Jews rule the media and
the industry and all of those things and
that that wasn't considered a minority
and wasn't worthy of of you which which
you know in a sense I don't agree with
that but I do agree that my by by
essence of being Jewish I shouldn't be
given a TV program but but if I have to
play his game yes you know so it's his
rules yes and I'm playing to his rules
but he's laughing because and this is a
pro I mean this is obviously David bedil
has done British comedians done this
Jews don't count bed's argument is a
little bit different to mine he he looks
at it as there's a whole industry around
wokeness and everybody is is comparing
you know where they are in the
oppression Olympics and Jews are not
included and that plays Into The
Stereotype um that Jews are wealthy and
super white and I agree with him about
that except I would say so let's
dismantle the whole thing we had this
debate when we had David on the show and
I did say to him you you know you've
identified all all the dots but you
refused to connect them and that's it
you know identity politics is bad and
it's especially bad for successful
minorities like East like U East Asians
in America like certain types of um
Africans like Jews Etc it's never going
to work out and and people need need to
understand that and by the way I so hear
what you said about not wanting to be a
victim and not wanting your background
to be used to your benefit I remember
when I was at school because I I was uh
English wasn't my first language uh they
would by the time I got to sort of GCSE
so that's 16 uh the the my teachers
would be like oh because you're foreign
you're allowed a dictionary to do your
exams and by this point I spoke English
as well if not better than most of my
classmates so I was like I don't want it
and they all looked at me like I was the
weird one the teachers and I was like it
was so obvious to me that you're not
supposed to get these benefits if you
genuinely don't need them it's like I
wouldn't want a wheelchair yeah some
people would though yeah and and and
that and they shouldn't be given one if
if they're not disabled you know what I
mean they're given metaphorical
wheelchairs all the time right yeah I I
think I think that's wonderful that's a
wonderful analogy I like I like that
that it sounds like that you remember
that Catch Me If You Can two two little
mice or whatever and one one drowns in
the what is it yogurt or something
cheese yeah the other one the other runs
so fast he turns the butter into
something solid I didn't write into but
milk into butter and climbs out and and
that's that Christopher Walkin what a
brilliant scene I I love that and in
that's the two what you've just said is
the two sides of the culture wars isn't
it people who say come on pull your
socks up you know make your bed we did
this we did our Jord peton uh
competition the other day uh and the
other side going like help everyone and
you know obviously sometimes you some
people need help you know but it just
there are also people who will take
advantage of that there'll be people who
didn't need that dictionary who are who
were born in England who speak English
who would say well oh constantin's got
well if you're offering it can I have
that dictionary as well cuz I can look
up the big words there are people like
that and they get to pass off you know
under the guise of of righteousness they
get to you know they get all the help
they want Andrew when I was doing my
research uh into this interview and I
was listening to some of your podcasts
it struck me that actually as a
documentary maker you are really
fearless and you were prepared to tackle
some subjects which a vast majority of
people simply won't want to go there and
we talked about it yes before my
interview with you particularly the
subject of
pedophilia and
your your work on that is striking so
let's talk about that honestly what was
the work about and what did you discover
well thank you uh FR that you know I I
never think of you don't think of
yourself as fair you know I'm scared of
everything but when you're working
you've sort of got a cloak on don't you
and you pretend you're not and um I
guess I was also just so desperate to to
make it at this at this point so I was
always like okay what's the stuff that
maybe Louis through wouldn't touch or
whatever and he has actually done that
topic to be fair um I'd moved from
Argentina at this point where I'd been
living for some years uh that's why I
did The Exorcist stuff and UFO stuff I
moved to Germany uh wanted to learn
German God Knows Why horrible um but but
whatever and while I was there it's like
okay what's the thing that I can do that
no one else wants to touch like no one
else wants to do here because that's the
only way I'm going to get into the media
so I'm still desperately pushing and
trying and it okay Nazis and neo-nazis
and there's Communists there and all
these things okay I'm looking at those
and then realized there were adverts on
the train there the Metro uh for
something called kind verden which means
don't offend and I'm immediately
intrigued as a journalist what the hell
is this so I looked it up and it is they
they say they were the world's only
therapy for non-offending pedophiles who
want to get help uh who will never
report them to authorities because uh an
American doctor would have to report
them and an Australian one or they could
actually face prison uh a British one I
don't think would face prison but would
be struck on
so they've got these you know so I
thought I don't know what I feel about
this and this is going to be scary and
obviously my girlfriend at the time now
my nearly my wife in a few months uh was
like what are you doing and I was like
yeah I'm going to do this and so I
emailed um the don't offend Clinic
people and said can I get in touch with
any of the patients I want to talk to
them and see what's what and they said
we can't just give you their emails we
don't even know them that's the whole
point that the doctors don't know the
real names of these people so they can't
report them but what they do is they
send out um in child sexual abuse
material in that people they will
download what they think is child sexual
abuse material and it's actually an
advert like hey you've got a problem
call this number which I think is great
that they that that's there um um and so
they go anonymously and whatever so the
clinician said uh what I can do is give
your email address out I'm like oh God
all these people are going to have my
email address but okay I'm look I'm
desperate at this point and I'm
fascinated there's there's no topic I'm
more fasc I mean what a fascinating
topic it is so I waited a few weeks
almost forgot about the whole thing and
then I get an email from someone who
calls himself Max from like a weird
email address bunch of numbers and
letters that I can't decipher and he
says hi Andrew I I heard about what
you're doing I can only meet today I'm
only in Berlin today this is where I'm
going to be and that's it and I was like
oh God okay got to I canceled going to
the lake with my girlfriend it's like
the summer lovely I'm really sorry I got
to go and meet a pedal and and she's
just like what and I'm like yeah sorry
and um so I go and meet him but just
before going to meet him I put the
address into Google Maps and it's a
public swimming pool and I'm like what
the hell what have I got myself into
here so my heart is going mad I've never
met someone like this I and I don't do
well in situations where I'm scared so I
really was scared cycle down to meet him
uh get into this public swimming pool
and I I find you know who he is and he
does look like what you you know it's
The Stereotype chubby guy he's got
Speedos got t-shirt over covering it
almost and he was with a little girl and
that shocked me so I said oh hi Max and
he's like oh hello I'm like right who's
who's and she just goes off to play and
I said who's the little girl um and he
said I'm babysitting her I okay oh this
is what have I got myself into cuz you
know at that point you're not even like
some guy with the BBC you know you're
just a guy on your own like I'm going to
be a reporter I've decided so you're
just guy on your own now at a public
swimming pool with a guy you know is a
pedophile who's babysitting children so
I'm now like worried for myself like
what have I got myself into and I'm
pushing him going you can't be
babysitting him what do you mean and he
goes no the mom knows about my condition
so that led me to go and meet the
mom CU I just didn't believe him and the
mom is then like yeah well she was like
super Lefty and I'm not just having to
go at leftwing people today I mean
there's a surprise mate it is a
thing unfortunately with the far left
it's the reason that a lot of people on
the right adopt pedophilia as one of
their key issues uh sort of military and
uh pedophilia we're going to get the get
those guys uh it's because the farle
with not necessarily deliberately but
their ideologies lead to that space if
you if you really push this idea of
everyone is oppressed and whatever it
can go there all behavior is a product
of Oppression that's it that's exactly
right and un you know people listening
will be going oh come on that's not true
we've got ample evidence of it over the
years that's not to say that there are
not just as many of these people these
criminal horrible people who do things
to children on the right there there are
but there's more permiss permissibility
is that word yeah permissiveness I think
yeah permissiveness on the left that's
the problem so we've seen it firstly
with um Kora boy home in Ireland uh
where the green party in Ireland were
involved in allowing um the Royal Mount
Batton uh Dicky Mount Batton to just go
and do what he wanted with the children
there um and we've seen it in Berlin
where we have something called the
kentler experiment that took place in
the ' 80s it was also the green party
far left who not there was a problem
where they had too many homeless boys
and too many pedophile men that they
didn't know what to do with and so they
placed the homeless boys with the
pedophiles in foster care with
pedophiles because that was a solution
to you know two birds with one stone
this sounds like something I'm making up
but it's it does it's all there it's all
New York New York Times I think covered
it or one of the New York one of the New
Yorker covered it it's it's all out
there except Berlin the government the
local government is still keeping a lot
of the uh papers under lock and key
because a lot of the people involved uh
are still alive who were responsible for
this travesty that took place but those
kids who were raised in those homes are
so messed up by it that they can hardly
speak now and that is just one example
of one of the issues I know I'm just
going on about the left today but the
far left that is one of the issues that
that can happen we'll be back with
Andrew in a minute but first do you
remember the Canadian trucker protest in
2022 where thousands of Canadians came
out to protest covid restrictions and
vaccine mandates now these protests
lasted for weeks and the people out on
the streets needed funds as any
Grassroots protest would so people set
up online crowdfunding campaigns which
raised millions of dollars incredible
but once the Canadian authorities had
started to criticize a crowdfunding
platforms ramping up pressure to close
the campaigns it didn't take long for
the biggest crowdfunding platform the
one we've all heard of to completely
capitulate and shut the campaigns down
now this is where our partners give send
go go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts gien go said
it respected diverse views and believed
hope and freedom are values worth
fighting for this is why we're proud to
partner with GI and go so if you need to
crowdfund for whatever means the most to
you then don't go to the big Tech
platforms we recommend you do it on give
send go starting a campaign on give
Sendo is easy and intuitive go to giv
send go.com today that's giv send go.com
to start raising money for whatever is
important to you and now back to the
interview so you meet this mother yeah
who's a far Lefty yeah and what what
happens from there she tells me it's all
fine she does this like weekly uh Meetup
with these guys who are minor attracted
persons as she calls them um who don't
offend now whether you trust that that
or not I you know I don't know I'm sure
some of them don't offend and I'm sure
some of them do and some of them watch
child sexual abuse material which to me
is just as bad because it encourages it
to be made more without without you
watching it it doesn't happen it doesn't
get made I speak to her and I push her
and push her she actually lets three of
her kids get babysat by this guy Max and
I said to her you know you might have
this experiment and this idealistic idea
and I get the idea again it's a nice
idea of like these guys are afflicted
with some sort of conditional illness
and they're trying really hard not to
offend and they don't I okay nice idea
and maybe they need to speak and and I
think they do need to speak uh I think
that will stop them offending as much
but that's that's you put yourself in
danger then don't put your kids in
danger because that's what's
happening that was pretty much the last
I saw of her she didn't want to speak to
me again after that because we had this
real not nice conversation Max continued
babysitting her children for some time I
continued talking to various other uh
pedophiles who would meet me some of
them uh I I understood what they were
saying you know they wanted help and
they would never touch a child they say
and I believe some of them some of them
said oh I did once when I was younger
and then I'm thinking oh I don't know
what to think the point is though that
the clinic what they're saying and I
think they really do have a point and I
think it's something we need to talk
about more um we we see this all kinds
of criminality that when people are made
to feel like they're monsters they are
more likely to retreat into the dark web
or the dark corners of the web and tell
one another that what they doing is okay
so we need to reach out to them in a way
where they can go to therapy and realize
how bad it is to abuse children because
they tell each other that it's okay and
this Clinic disabuses them of that
notion they say some of the a good
percentage of these people there 1% of
the population of the male population
have this Affliction or whatever it is
uh the clinic believes it's very hard to
find empirical evidence unfortunately
with this kind of thing they believe
that there are many who are psychopaths
and there's nothing they can do about
those people there are many who will
never offend CU they just know it's a
terrible thing to do and where the
clinic helps is with the people in the
middle who could offend if they for
example got drunk around children if
they're around children too much or if
they fell in with a crowd and there are
many crowds like this who tell them that
it's okay so for that reason they need
to come out and and speak to therapists
and at the moment outside of Germany
that's not possible so that that's a
concern because if you're worried about
child abuse and again all there's all
different kinds of Statistics but some
say that one in three or four kids are
abused some say one in six or one in
nine but it's a lot I mean even one in
100 is too many MH so at the moment on
the left we're saying don't talk about
this because I'm getting triggered on
the right we're saying lock them all up
and kill them all and that that's
obviously not something we can actually
do so I think we need to go let's calm
down and talk about this and we can
actually save children's lives hopefully
that's the idea and was a clinic
effective or is is Clinic effective in
dealing with this particular issue they
don't know that's the problem they are
going on faith they it's their philosop
their philosophy is it must help because
they're coming in and we are talking to
them and making them understand how bad
this is and even if it just helps with
one guy and stops them from committing
that heinous act on one child that's a
job well done but they can't really go
around going hang on was that the guy
who committed that thing afterwards and
that's the biggest criticism labeled at
the don't offend clinic in Germany and
and it's that's an issue I agree that's
an issue but I don't know yet what the
way around that is do you know what you
were saying about the mother who who was
allowing her kids to be Babys
hat it's something that I talk about a
lot which is how few people in the west
and you're right it is more one side of
the political Spectrum than the other
but also I think the writer is also very
naive about
this ideology is the most powerful
driver of human behavior that I can
think of and you can get people to do
incredibly awful illogical irrational
self-harming harming their own children
which is even worse and self Haring
things simply because they've been
presented with a world view that they've
fully B into that's that's shocking to
me well I started my my channel and as
you guys know I changed it to a new
channel now um but but the I started it
as Cults that was the idea Cults Cults
and cult ideologies the problem was once
I started talking about how some of the
sort of Lefty woke stuff is cultish
everyone turned on me and I had to
create this new channel that's what
Francis came on Heretics but the first
channel was Cults and the links between
like a Scientology cult and the way
scientologists feel and the way uh
Jonestown and Heaven's Gate were and
some of the political ideologies it's
the same thing and I I've got a good
friend now who's an ex Scientologist
called Aaron Smith Levan and he says all
the time he's such a well-rounded guy he
was born into Scientology so he didn't
like you know drink the Kool-Aid or
whatever he he's he's a good guy guy and
he says when I was in it there is
nothing you could have said to me
nothing that would have made me not
believe in Scientology not you know and
Scientology believes in an
intactics of people in a volcano and and
all this mad stuff so that's how far it
goes and I think once you've dealt with
those kinds of stories to then come back
and go like oh maybe nihal hasn't got it
exactly right and he wants to imagine
that the demographics are different for
the BBC than they actually are that's
not a stretch I mean if people can
believe uh I mean gate they believed
that they were going to go to an alien
planet they all killed themselves like
they it wasn't Kool-Aid it was something
else that was Jones Town actually it
wasn't Kool-Aid it was something else uh
I don't know what they drunk exactly but
they they all took their own lives
that's how far people can go so yeah the
the idea that this woman could let her
own kids be taken out by a guy she knows
is a pedophile babysitter that's how far
ideology is that's what people I want
people to take take away exactly what
You' just said like if that's how far
they can go imagine just like politics
how we might all be be a little bit you
know blinkered and what was her
rationale because that's other thing I'm
curious about because I might think for
example that somebody is absolutely an
ex
smoker but I wouldn't let them
deliberately babysit packs of
cigarettes do you know what I mean that
what is the rationale behind giving your
children to somebody who is hopefully a
non-offending what what why did she do
this well yeah I I said to her it's like
an alcoholic behind a bar you know um
she says because it means a lot to her
it's her life's work so that's the IDE
ideological side it's that very very
dangerous thing of feeling good about
yourself and now she has a huge group of
people who no one else will speak to
them except her so she goes from being
like Mrs boring cuz she is just boring
plain person she's a boring to superhero
among those people so that's that's what
she and then at that point every it's
like Cults right so one of the first
parts of being in a cult is you get love
bombed right right people start love
buming you people telling her how
wonderful she's never heard that before
she's having a you know like most of us
who's telling us how wonderful we are
apart from the three of us together you
know so what an amazing feeling that's
what Scientology does that's what all of
the Cults do and that's what's happened
unfortunately to her she's being told
wonderful wonderful you're thinking
about things in a way that no one else
is how wonderful you are um and so those
guys going hey you know what I'd really
love like no one would ever trust me
with their kids you know and blah blah
blah you believe us that we never offend
and by the way it might be that this guy
really doesn't offend and didn't want
anything to do with the kids in that way
he's still taking them through a
changing why is he babysitting kids
though why at a pool why a swimming pool
why anywhere why is not a a common thing
for a man to want to babysit someone
else's children I mean someone else's
children generally speaking are quite
annoying oh it's the worst thing in the
world right they're awful so the fact
that this is a guy that wants to do that
and completely unrelated happens to be a
non-offending
pedophile it's a little bit sus I'm just
call me a cynic the way it works I think
these guys don't okay I'm speaking in
general about a lot of the non-offenders
from what they've told me and then
listeners and viewers can make their own
minds up about to what extent they
should believe these guys they don't
just have a sexual attraction to them
which is disgusting and needs to be you
know eradicated as as much as it can be
but they also feel like they have some
sort of platonic they love being around
children so I spoke to an 18-year-old
who has this uh a boy who was or guy who
was a pres Club School president mhm uh
at his school which is you know bad I I
don't know his real name I don't know
the school but we spoke uh just via
Skype I didn't meet him in real life and
he kept saying the same thing and he
said I'm going to go to these I do all
these clubs and after school activities
where I look after the kids so everyone
thinks he's wonderful and amazing he
looks after the kids like Jimmy savvo
did you know he's really involved with
the kids but he said he said to me this
really weird thing and he said Andrew
you need to understand um if I weren't
able to do that I would be more likely
to offend because it's so important to
me that I can be around kids and I love
it so much that it would screw me up so
much not being around them and I said
but you know that doesn't make sense
because if you weren't near the kids you
couldn't physically do it and he was
going no no you don't get it so those
are the cognitive biases that you need
to disabuse these people of and this is
possible that that this guy Max who was
babysitting the kids I mean the other
question is he knew he was meeting me a
journalist and he wanted to give this uh
he wanted to show it's rare that
journalists want to meet one of these
guys so he wanted to show hey we're all
above board and I spent months after
thinking what was he trying to show was
he trying to show uh Defiance like screw
you I would never do anything to a kid
just cuz I have this thing why would you
assume that here I am at a swimming pool
with the kids and he took it too far and
it had the opposite effect maybe that's
what he was trying to do these are
generally not well-rounded individuals
unfortunately these These are people
that there's a theory there's no
consensus people don't know exactly what
causes is this conditional illness uh
but there's a theory that people get
sort of stuck at a moment in time that
when you look at people like Jimmy savil
who had a terrible childhood uh in
abject poverty pneumonia things like
that that is very possible Michael
Jackson uh awful childhood of abuse it's
often cyclical um so that is a theory
that people have you get stuck in that
moment and it's it's your your
development doesn't quite work and you
still feel like a child and you like
being around children so that's all can
you know that I'm strong Manning why he
would do that but the thing that I found
really interesting about you talking to
that 18yearold is to me quite telling
because he was saying unless I'm around
kids then I'm the real victim
here yeah and that to me sums up a lot
of what we're talking about it's this
desire for victimhood status whereby if
I can't be put in a position where I'm a
direct threat to children then I'm a
victim and you go
how insane is that logic and that way of
thinking and that people would agree to
that yeah he Hoodwinked you know himself
firstly I believe he really believes
that in himself and he hoodwinks this
woman who now runs a whole therapy class
for a bunch of them and she's not part
you know what happens with this Berlin
Clinic Berlin Clinic don't offend I
think okay I think that there's some
good here this is just a woman like
nothing to do with anything who happens
to be quite leftwing and who believes
that this is another minority victim who
who needs help in that respect and we
talk about cults and before when I was
younger I used to watch documentaries on
Cults I think we all did and I used to
think you know a guy with a cult the
cult would be like a guy with in robes
with long hair talking about some
ridiculous thing and there'd be about
200 people and there'd be some dodgy sex
involved and blah blah blah and the
older I get the more I look around
whether it's wokeism whether it's you
know islamists and I go this is all a
cult we are surrounded by Cults yeah in
a way that I didn't understand and my
eyes weren't open to before it's but
it's human dynamics isn't it and I I
feel the same as you and that's why you
know my old I say old channel it's still
going I still go with it but recently I
started talking about like I say talking
about how this is really similar but
there's an Unwritten rule among sort of
the people on YouTube who talk about
cults which is that we don't get
political and I've tried to say like
that doesn't make sense though because
politics is everywhere as Ricky jaas I
think said once but uh it's it's all
part of the same thing and how can you
possibly separate those things what they
really mean though a lot of these people
who are ex Cults a lot of them they were
in Cults themselves and there's the Zeal
of the what's the expression I can't
remember now the Zeal of the convert or
whatever uh these people who leave those
Cults tend to join new Cults uh and that
tends to be because the Cults they were
in tend to have things we associate with
the rights which is homophobia you you
can't be gay in Scientology Tom Cruz
would not admit that it's apparent there
are rumors that's why Tom Cruz and John
Travolta don't get on because John
Travolta allegedly might be gay um and
that's an issue that's a huge issue in
Scientology you cannot be gay in
Scientology it suggests there is
something very wrong with you hidic
Judaism uh Evangelical Christianity you
can't be gay you can't individual
liberties not there all those kinds of
things so people leave those Cults of
extreme religions and they go the other
way and people saying oh fantastic come
to our group I've got blue hair and then
they've got blue hair and everyone's got
blue hair again and we're they're like
oh God I hat hated when I was in those
Cults hey and they're all with the blue
hair they're all having and they're
saying things like trans women are women
and I always are I just say but are you
saying are are you using the word are
and they're going yes they are women I
go what no but that's not a thing that
can't that that has to be a slogan you
don't you recognize this from when you
were in the C just because this is the
seems to be the other side of the
ideology can't you see they don't see it
because these are people who are prone
to joining Cults so I agree with you
absolutely basically you know and based
on what you've noticed I'm curious if
you have any insight into whether there
is a certain type of person who has more
of a predilection for uh joining Cults
and for believing things of the nature
that you've just described there is and
again you're not supposed to say it it's
an unwritten law when you talk about
cults because of the victimhood
mentality that you're supposed to say it
can happen to anyone if you went into a
cult it doesn't say there's anything
particular about you that might need to
be addressed in therapy you're a
wonderful person and any of us could
have gone but let's be honest the three
of us probably would never have joined
Scientology right it just couldn't have
I'd never join a cult I might lead
one I join that cult I think we're in it
yeah you don't want to join my it's no
but it's it's but you were saying it's
not that it could happen to anyone no
the truth is the truth is you need to be
very vulnerable in this time of life uh
in a particular time of life so one
person is Steve Hassan he's known as
like the Godfather of Cults because he
came up with something called The Bite
model which is how to recognized a cult
okay and he's an intellect and he's an
academic but what happened to him is
that when he was in his 20s uh three
women in the library started talking to
him and they were being all sexy and
stuff and they convinced him to join
something called the Moonies which was
led by someone called reverend Moon who
believed he was the second coming of
Christ and who are homophobic far right
blah blah blah blah blah and he just
upped and joined it again no matter how
attractive those three women are I'd
imagine we wouldn't have joined the
Moonies he's now the expert in it and it
does frustrate me sometimes that a lot
of the experts talk to he wrote about
the cult of trump now but he doesn't
want to talk about the cult of some of
the Lefty ideology stuff so I sort of
want to say to him like well hang on
mate like I I didn't join a cult and
most of the listeners didn't and most of
us you did so maybe we should tell you
what to do rather than you advise us so
I think what does happen is people who
need to feel special that's what no one
wants to say these are people desperate
to feel special desperate to feel like
they were a victim their whole lives and
there is something special about
scientology something special about the
Moonies or whatever and those people
when they leave the cult still want to
feel special so it's that needing to
feel very special I think but isn't that
quite a common thing like I I would have
thought most people want to feel special
in some way like everyone uh everyone's
kind of the hero of their own movie and
and I think um obviously we've talked a
lot about wokeness on the show in
history historically speaking and I
think it's undoubtedly the case that the
the world view which is based on
oppression structures and uh
institutional discrimination and uh
systemic this it is a world view that
says that the world is against you and
that is a world view that is predicated
on you being special otherwise why would
the world be against you if you're just
like everyone else right then the world
is agnostic about you the world doesn't
care about you uh the world is what it
is and it's your job to make the best of
that but if you think the world is
uniquely out to get you that is a
worldview that is about being special
isn't it yeah 100% well 100% well that's
why it's the same PE we all want to feel
special as you say some of us realize
like well unfortunately we are no
unfortunately we can't all be or we
can't we can't have a society where
every one of the 8 billion of us get
special treatment and so let's try and
uh subdue that need to feel special
other people go well hang on what's this
Scientology thing I get to so so Alex
Barnes Ross is someone I know friendly
with him now an English Scientologist we
don't get so many of them but but um
Elon harbard the creator of Scientology
did spend a lot of time in um England uh
and there was there is a there is some
there are Scientologist here um and he
said it was really attractive to him
apart from the love buming and feeling
special because he didn't feel special
at school or anything like that was that
he was able to go and cure the reactive
mind he was going to be able to go and
evangelize and make other people realize
that Scientology is the true way and
that they basically they're the bad guys
and he's the good guy I mean what does
that sound like like it you know what it
sounds like because to me it sounds that
people who are higher than average on
narcissism are prone to either forming
Cults or joining a cult I think so yeah
which you can understand whilst looking
at it because if you think about a
conspiracy theorist somebody who's
really into conspiracy theories and
eulogizes about them what are they
effectively saying you don't understand
the world the way that I do and I have a
very special it which no one else does I
mean that is highly narcissistic y I
think so I think so and you know what
happens is I mean at the moment the
Scientologist there's a big ex
Scientology Community I'm in with all
these I didn't think that would happen
and that's the thing now I'm in with the
ex Scientologist and some of them are
really lovely guys I get on with really
well but they've had what was inevitable
a huge civil war between the ex
scientologists who have slightly
different beliefs about how ex
Scientology should be it's just human
beings isn't it it's hilarious uh Andrew
listen it's been such a pleasure
chatting before we uh head on over and
get some of our audience questions for
you uh you mentioned uh starting a new
channel which I'm just curious about
because uh it's quite a hard thing to do
to change channels why did you do it and
how how he found that I was a a victim
of very a victim a victim a victim of
Life the system came to get you the
system got me I was a victim of audience
capture which basically means I was I
was um uh I wanted loads of money and so
when I started my channel I got very
excited okay we'll talk about
scientology then this then that and I
started realizing okay but if if I've
got Tom Cruz in the thumbnail it does
really well okay let's do another one
about Tom Cruz and now John travala and
now Megan marle and then suddenly it
went from what I wanted the channel to
be to and it's my own fault of course to
celebrity stuff a lot of it and then
when I put out the stuff I really cared
about which is very similar to what you
guys do no not only did people not watch
it but they got angrier and angrier
because these were people who were there
for the cult stuff and they didn't
believe that the woke stuff was a cult
stuff it was a cult thing and recently
with the Israel stuff it that just died
a death so I can still do a live stream
and say look at what's happened to
Prince Harry and Megan and it will get
hundreds of thousands of views just
talking to the camera but that's not
fulfilling me in my life and I got to
interview because of that channel it
gave me some prominence which allowed me
to interview top guests like Francis
Foster uh and greme linan and Winston
Marshall and Helen Joyce and all these
kinds of Richard Dawkins um fantastic oh
I I'm so happy Channel called it's
called Heretics and yeah that that
that's it and it's it's I hope I hope
people come and absolutely well we'll
make sure to link to it's been really
great to chat with you let's keep in
touch and and and do this again some
time uh before we go to questions from
our supporters as you know the last
question we always ask is what's the one
thing that we're not talking about that
we should be I was thinking about this
and I thought um lookism is an
interesting one and I think that's going
to maybe be the next thing that happens
because I was reading at Ted Chang who
one of my favorite authors he's like a
scientist author and he made this short
story about a school that has a where
they use like magnets or whatever to
turn off the receptor in your brain that
can recognize attraction in people so
these people grew up not knowing if they
were attractive or their friends were
attractive um there are also very real
experiments going on at the moment where
about mind reading and being able to
tell someone's attributes and things so
you don't have to give a CV anymore you
will be able to just read their minds
and know if they're going to be good at
certain things and I think that a lot of
what we've spoken about with regards to
Obsession and control among author
itarian people I think that's could be
that's one of the potentials for a
future Clash where some people are
saying you've got to turn off your
attraction bias in certain uh places and
schools and things and and all these
kinds of things so that's something that
I think we need to look out for that's
insane that's insane anyway uh if you
want to hear more insane stuff head on
over to locals or elsewhere where you
support us to get Andrew's answers to
your
questions what was your most disturbing
interview or
[Music]
guest